humans thrive when they make meaningful
connections
[Music]
successful businesses are no different
today
connecting with customers means
delivering valuable digital experiences
and cloud services promise fully
connected teams who deliver its speed
but often using multiple clouds
threatens to impede
rather than drive growth with
versatility come burdens of complexity
such as friction integrating clouds
incompatible platform experiences and
security
fragmented visibility endless upgrades
and difficulty with onboarding scarce
talent
enter ibm cloud satellite a managed
distributed cloud solution that delivers
consistent cloud services
anywhere you want them on-prem
in any cloud or at the edge teams
connect through the same user experience
and access
any secured satellite location in the
same way
a single view shows pipelines
deployments and services running in
every satellite location
consider the benefits to a financial
service company expanding into new
markets
as required by law their solution must
be able to handle and store data locally
and any payments the system receives
must be acknowledged within two seconds
to satisfy industry regulations using
satellite
it's not a problem and because satellite
locations are consistent with each other
teams develop software once and deliver
anywhere
with ibm managing satellite services the
business expands
without expanded operations monitoring
worldwide operations remains effortless
now across all satellite locations
thanks to equal access to artificial
intelligence
and over 200 other cloud services
development teams can focus
exclusively on staying connected with
customers
ibm cloud satellite build lasting
connections with consistent cloud
services
in any industry anywhere
you